my channel is sponsored by manscaped
which means we will hear more from them
somewhere in the middle of this video
hello everyone and welcome to another q
a this one is a personal q a um which
means that i answer questions about
everything other than video games so you
can leave questions about whatever you
want below and i will just like pull
them into the relevant q a basically uh
obviously i'm not at home right now
which is why my background looks
i just feel like this looks like what
every
like 50 plus year old actor when they
join one of those table read zoom calls
looks like this is what the background
of every actor i've ever seen be
interviewed
looks like it's always the same set to
be fair i feel like my webcam is
slightly better quality than uh they
would usually
yeah in case it's not obvious i'm just
not at home right now evidently first
question from hannah nelson i don't know
if you get asked this all the time but
i've been wondering what makes slash
brand is your headphones slash headset
and mic love your videos thank you
hannah i use an elgato wave 3 microphone
which is what this is um at home i have
it connected to a mic arm but when i
travel i take it off and i just attach
this base to it
um and it is it's a really good
microphone i am very very happy with it
um the headphones that i usually wear
when i'm at home are
there windows surface headphones um the
white ones and i love them they are
falling apart so i need to either
replace them or find a new headset
sometime soon the windows surface
headphones have this really cool thing
where like you spin one of the ears
forwards
and it will um put on noise cancellation
so you won't be able to hear anything
and then you spin it backwards and it
will actually amplify voices so if
someone is like across another side of
an office from you and you spin it
backwards if you couldn't hear what they
were saying it will heighten them even
if you listen to music or something so
it has like a noise cancellation and a
voice amplification built in they're
super cool i really like them td goldie
said hey alana i know you're not exactly
some kind of drama channel but i really
wanted to hear your thoughts on the
frost gear in g4 rant and the subsequent
drama that has followed so for anyone
who doesn't know i didn't know about it
um frost i don't know if if this person
actually goes by frost or frost gear and
i don't know how to say it frosk is a
host at g4 a female presenter
um
i don't watch g4 uh so i can't really
comment on what frost necessarily does i
don't actually know i do have friends
who work there and i'm uh very
supportive of those people and and the
brand in general i don't doubt that i
will collaborate with them more i have
before they did actually offer me a job
outright but obviously i said no because
i don't want to be a host
i want to write video games so that is
what i'm doing um and
it was clifton put on twitter this this
um
i don't know rant i guess um where she
speaks about
some of the sexist harassment that she
gets
by being a host on g-fool and i have no
doubt that
a lot of what she said in this is true
um
because you can go and you can see it
even the people who like this isn't
about sexism
uh in their replies are still saying sex
is [ __ ] there's just like no world in
which she hasn't dealt with a bunch of
sexist garbage um it's just there's just
no way that's not to say that i think
all game is a sexist or any of that
nonsense because i absolutely do not
that is definitely not a thing um
but yes she she basically like spoke
about
uh people criticizing her appearance
which has happened to me constantly i'm
either too fat or i'm not pretty enough
constantly as a female host i got those
comments i people still all the time um
quite frequently get angry at me for my
nails
you're like you need a [ __ ] manicure
what the [ __ ] i have men get angry at me
for the way that my nails look all the
time i'd always be like what what
why on earth do you care that i have
short nails what does that have to do
with anything that i'm saying so i have
no doubt that what she's saying
in that video is correct and has
happened to her and then it would be
very easy to find again i did actually
find examples even from people who were
saying that it wasn't because she was a
woman who would then using very sexist
language to attack her so clearly that's
part of it even if it wasn't like the
root cause so then i dug a little deeper
into like why this had happened just out
of curiosity i guess and it was sparked
by people getting very angry at her for
saying something um that i vehemently
disagree with her on which was something
along the lines of playstation is dead
in the water this year playstation has
nothing coming out this year there are
so many cool playstation games coming
out this year like
sifu and horizon next month to start
with um
that i'm more excited about than most of
the rest of the year so there are all
these comments saying she's not being
harassed because she's a woman she's
harassed because she said this
and that is the part that i can't get
behind i can look at a comment where i
hear somebody say playstation is dead in
the water in 2022
and i can disagree with it and be like
damn harsh what about gorilla and all of
the people who worked on
horizon who were very excited about that
game and i can look at that and i can
still
have no interest in harassing her that's
that's the thing so for all these people
who are like it's not sexist we're
harassing her because of what she said
about playstation and xbox
my response is okay but you're still
harassing her
why do you think that makes it any
better like i get that technically it's
better to harass someone over console
wars than it is
over their gender but when it comes down
to it i'm like the people who are saying
that you're just admitting that you're
still just harassing somebody because
they have less interest in playstation
than xbox like
that's not that doesn't make it okay
that's not some grand excuse or or some
justification you're still just [ __ ]
harassing somebody for sharing their
opinion and even if i strongly disagree
with what she said there
no part of me is mad at her thinks it
means she's not qualified thinks it
means she should be fired
none of that
i'm just like i disagree
that's about it i don't doubt even that
i would meet her in person at some point
like that seems pretty likely and i have
no opinion of her personally based on my
disagreement with what she said but
literally nothing
no part of me wants to go and tweet at
her no part of me feels the need to say
anything because somebody shared an
opinion that is different to mine again
and i'm saying that as someone who it
feels like a little bit closer to home
because i know people at gorilla and i
have loads of friends who work at
playstation but even then i still i
still am like
you're allowed to say whatever you want
and that's fine if she prefers the
lineup of xbox games
that's totally fine that is no cause to
harass somebody
under any circumstances it is time to
talk about mansky valentine's day is
coming up
might be time to start
thinking about trimming those rose
bushes
we are of course talking about
landscaping your balls well thank you i
feel like i get too much enjoyment out
of doing these ad reads but i digress
this valentine's day maybe it's time to
join the 4 million men worldwide who
trust manscaped to get them ready this
is the performance package 4.0 kit which
features this beautiful lawnmower 4.0
you can use it for beard maintenance but
the coolest thing about it is that it's
built with advanced skin safe technology
which helps reduce nicks and cuts on the
most sensitive areas spotlight and
everything it's also waterproof which is
definitely going to come in here we also
have the crop preserver and the crop
reviver big fan of both of these crop
reviver is a ball toner
smells delicious and the crop preserver
is an anti-chafing clear gel liquid
deodorant formulated exclusively to keep
your boys from sweating smelling and
sticking the kit also features the weed
whacker ear and nose hair trimmer which
has 360 degree rotary blades and the
same skin safe technology from the body
trimmer so it helps prevent tugging and
tears on your nose they now also have
this new and improved shears 2.0 luxury
6-piece stainless steel nail kit and a
bunch of new liquid products for the
shower too and for a limited time when
you buy the performance package 4.0 kit
you'll also get two free gifts the shed
travel bag and the manscaped
anti-shaping boxer briefs so break up
your old grooming routine and get with
the performance package from manscape
don't wait go to manscape.com and use my
promo code alana 20 to get 20 off plus
free international shipping plus two
free gifts now back to the video so the
like excuse that's being used is like
we're not attacking her because she's a
woman but then again so many of them
default to ugly [ __ ] nobody wants to
[ __ ] you like well
you're doing the thing that you said you
weren't doing so
she's right but even if there weren't
the sexist language in the harassment
afterwards even if it were just you're
an idiot this is the dumbest [ __ ] i've
ever heard i can't believe you have a
job type of stuff you'd still just be
going and
sending a lot of angry tweets at
somebody
just because they said something about a
console that you don't agree with
i don't think there's
any part of it that i can get behind
no matter what really you're just still
harassing someone you know
and that's not to say that criticism
isn't allowed to be clear because
you know
the console wars fanboys will certainly
criticize you that's to be expected um
but in this instance she is being
harassed it's not the same thing it's
not saying something that people don't
agree with or that people
think is stupid or whatever and and
having people come and tweet you and
tell you
it is way worse than that like the
volume of what is being thrown at her
the amount of videos being made about it
i guess i'm technically adding to that
people tell me that i'm wrong about [ __ ]
i've said like every day
and it doesn't waver into harassment
until they are trying to get other
people on board in my opinion when it
becomes harassment is when i see
somebody
trying to get everybody else to also
feel that way
that's when i'm like oh this person is
is targeting this is trying to create
something out of this
is trying to push people towards this
even if it doesn't affect me that's what
i tend to draw the line at and be like
oh that's okay
that's a different thing and she's
certainly got plenty of that coming her
way right now just [ __ ] just leave
her a lot that would be my whole thing
care about anything else okay just care
about anything else other than people on
the internet not agreeing with you you
cannot follow them you could just leave
that is fine
i feel like 2022 is gonna be a great if
playstation and for xbox and for
nintendo i'm really excited to play
pokemon tomorrow which related i'm not
streaming this month i stopped streaming
for the rest of january because i have
the script that i just really wanted to
finish and i was like well
if i don't stream i can use the hours i
spend streaming on writing
and so that's what i'm doing so there
are no streams so i'm not streaming
arceus or recording the first hour of it
like i normally would but i will be back
to that next month when i finish the
script stephen goodman said have you
danced around your new apartment singing
into your hairbrush yet like tom cruise
and risky business haven't seen it uh
but i know the reference because of
funhouse
i unfortunately am not that [ __ ]
i wish i was i wish i was i look at
people like
liza koshy i think is how you pronounce
her name people who just like these
little bundles of energy you know and i
wish that that was me i wish that i
could be
dance around my apartment into a
hairbrush girl
but i just don't have it in me i'm so
low
you know
very calm all the time
not a lot of spontaneous dancing
unfortunately
that said i have no mood swings i feel
like that's the upside of being
extremely calm and even tempered all the
time is that i have no moods i'm just
always okay i wake up every morning
and i'm just okay
i'm good
there's no variation on it i'm just
always yeah i'm good that said i have
been playing a significant amount more
emo music for whatever reason
i've been putting hawthorne heights
because now i have multiple rooms so i
put multiple speakers like i put
speakers in every room and then i just
play
across all rooms it's just really novel
to me that i have multiple rooms okay
i'm very excited about it troublesome
said hope that you don't mind me asking
what is going to happen to player watch
listen with everything that happened
with troy
i said this on this week's episode which
i guess is not up yet i have no
intentions of making any changes to play
watch listen
but he is super busy at the moment i
also don't want to speak on his path he
is super busy at the moment i know that
uh you know we knew i think in december
that he probably wouldn't be able to be
on the show at all in february
um so i feel like he probably won't see
troy for the next like month or whatever
but uh
that is
not really related i'm certainly not
kicking him off the show i don't think
the show is going to go anywhere and i
think anything is going to change
he's not on twitter right now i assume
which is why we do most of our play
watch listen chats because he's not been
in the messages there so i don't know i
don't really know what his plan is uh i
couldn't tell you kidoka 88 said i
really love the look from your friend's
camera in the going back to fun house
video any plans of getting something
like that so this is the person who is
referring to the camera
appearance of the camera in the q a that
i made from ethan's house um and
obviously people commented on it i look
like a different person it's so wild
it's so strange
how just like good lighting and a proper
camera setup could make you look like a
different person um
i no i have no intention of getting a
fancy camera uh i'm not a content
creator full-time obviously i spend a
lot of my after hours time doing it but
it's not my job so
i don't really want to spend a thousand
dollars on a camera just for some
youtube videos um i don't feel like my
channel makes enough money to justify
that and i also kind of take issue with
the idea that if my content looks
professional then people expect
professionalism and i can't do that like
sometimes i'll just disappear for a
month uh because
it's not my job so if you don't look
like you're a super professional content
creator people don't expect you to be
one and i think that works out in my
favor the fact that it is like really
more a a a hobby and something that i do
after hours
coincides with the fact that i don't
have like a cool studio set up um and i
don't want to have to like change my
office space to accommodate for that
either like my content creation side of
my office right now is also just my
gaming pc so it's kind of set up for me
to play games there as well and then the
other side of my office is my work side
and most of it is decorated for my work
side so like the office is basically
covered in god of war stuff right now um
and because i do spend more time in
there working as in doing sms work than
i do doing content creation i don't want
to like change that whole space to be
about content creation which is the
thing that takes
i don't know not even an hour a day
where everything else takes way more
time so yeah i don't have any intention
of ever upgrading beyond a webcam
um
maybe one day but i i
don't feel like it really makes sense
for what my goals are
i don't feel like the expense really
makes sense and i don't want to have to
move my setup or change things just to
get
uh
a larger camera set up
in that space when that's the space is
still also my like work office so that
part is more important to me i hope that
makes sense it makes sense in my head
that if i'm making stuff on a webcam
from anywhere in the world that nobody
expects consistent uploads or whatever i
feel like that works
alrighty that is it for me today
everybody remember you can leave
questions for the next one in the
comments of this q a
uh the next one will be all about gaming
but you can ask really whatever you want
to pull it from either of the q and a's
thank you to manscape for sponsoring the
channel they are a very fun sponsor to
work with
i will have a link for them in the
description below
i will see you guys next time bye